Albert breeder covers the league mmm QB
and NBC sports Boston Albert we started
the show we were looking for the third
best wide receiver in NFL history modern
day era if we assume it's Jerry Rice and
then it's Randy Moss should we assume
Moss is second on that list all time
right there was Moss I covered both them
you know the one thing the one
difference between the two were I think
it gives Ahmad Collins I think Owens was
a little harder shut down like Moss as
spectacular as he was and as dominant as
he could be there was a certain way that
you could take him out of a game when
was Owens at his very best and you can
go back and look there's a one-month
period there with the Cowboys during
that 2007 season we're here about six or
seven hundred yards receiving and ten
touchdowns and I was covering the
Cowboys Ben and I just tell ya like
there was nothing anybody could do to
stop and so I think Moss probably had a
little bit better of a career but no
one's had this ability to be almost
uncover about that I'm not sure mosque
white hat who else is in that
conversation as the second or third best
receiver of all time modern day or just
trying to think I mean Rice's obviously
I think rice is far and away number one
Larry Fitzgerald
I think Fitz would be in there I mean
Calvin Johnson for a sort of period of
time was so dominant but I guess that
would almost be like a Gayle sayers type
thing you know where it just didn't last
that long yeah I mean III think Calvin
will be that that category Larry
Fitzgerald obviously for the longevity
and that the ability to pivot and almost
reinvent himself as a player later in
his career yeah somewhat similar to what
those the way the way rice did it late
in his career yeah I mean yes
I think those would be the guys I mean I
don't know if you get into like the
Marvin Harrison's were know Marvin was a
very good you know very very good
receiver for a long time in a dominant
offense you got a lot of guys like that
so I you know the other thing is tough
Dan it's just you know you go air-to-air
and the numbers don't match ah you know
I mean you can go back into the 70s and
I love guys like Lynn salon and if you
match them up numbers it's just it
doesn't even look like those guys are
close and so much that's about
opportunity we talked about Terrell
Owens not going to Canton Ohio
but is it true that the players are
trying to have this initiative where you
must sign a document promising that
you'll attend the induction ceremony are
we close to that actually being reality
yeah I know Mike Soria reported that I
haven't heard that myself
you know so I don't know how close that
is to being reality or not I would just
make the argument here that and look
I've talked to some guys who are in the
hall saying about this I like I just
think that you know the Hall of Fame is
a museum that's supposed to celebrate
the history of the game and to take
pieces of pieces of the history of the
game out just to prop up the Hall of
Fame weekend I personally think would be
wrong I think with the Hall of Fame is
therefore is you know 458 you know in 50
or a hundred years someone can walk in
there and they can they can see and read
about Terrell Owens and Randy Moss and
all these great players who came you
know a long time before the guys win the
game now and so I like to me it's just I
like I personally have always felt like
it's silly to take pieces of history of
the game out of a place like that just
in order to prop up some ceremony or
somebody again in one sentence why
wasn't Terrell Owens a first-ballot
hall-of-famer I personally think that a
lot of the people on the committee tells
his locker room issues against him and
you know I understand it's sort of a
gray area because
you're not supposed to take off the old
things into consideration and you know
it's how the guy's a teammate it tell
the guy conducts himself in the locker
room was that is that a factor you know
I think you can argue that both ways
whether or not should be or it shouldn't
be III just you know III would say this
he was so dominant for a number of years
that I don't know how anybody to look at
that and say you know him doing sit-ups
in his driveway or whatever would
outweigh his accomplishments on the
field you know but the thing is Albert I
don't understand this it almost it feels
like we hold your more accountable for
what you are as a teammate than what you
were doing outside of that where you
might have been arrested or somebody you
know was caught with drugs and hookers
in a hotel room or you know suspended
for drugs or Brett Favre was he a great
teammate if he was you know on
painkillers
you know that's what I'm not sure I just
I think we need to be fair to Terrell
Owens yeah and I don't know for being
fair I think we're picking and choosing
with him yeah I agree
just again like I I've always looked at
the Hall of Fame as a museum not a
church you know like it's it's there to
explain the history of the game to tell
the story of great players and I've
always thought with the barometer for
for getting the Hall of Fame is can you
tell the story and I really think it'd
be difficult to tell the sort of the
area Hollins played in without talking
about Terrell Owens and I know that
there you know you can play games with
that too or they're certain like you
can't tell a story of this decade
without on the story of Aaron Hernandez
it doesn't mean he should be a Hall of
Fame you know but I think that there are
you know there are guys who made an
impact on the field that you know you
just can't tell us sort of the game
without them and I just think Terrell
was one of those guys and I do think
part of it is you know the way that the
way that he treated certain people in
the media and I don't think that's fair
at all I don't think that the fact that
you know maybe he could be prickly to
deal with their pain
like I've never felt like that should
have anything to do with anybody going
into you know going into any Hall thing
so that's just been my opinion on it
that you know you should you should
mostly hold this is this should be
mostly about your accomplishments on the
field and I do think that it's fair to
look at like who he is as a teammate is
I think that can be a little bit of a
gray area just because it does affect
what happens on the field you know but I
got I actually like the way football
does it where they take the off take
mostly off the old stuff out of it
because like I just don't think those
committees should be you know any sort
of moral moral arbiter the we're talking
Albert Brie or the mm QB and NBC Sports
Boston Kelvin Benjamin no longer with
Cam Newton in Carolina but some partying
shots there a couple of years after the
fact where he wishes he would have
played for a I guess a smarter
quarterback a more accurate quarterback
was what Kelvin Benjamin saying actually
true I mean we look at it go boy how can
you criticize him but did he did he say
something that's factually correct I
don't for most receivers I think I ain't
playing with Cam Newton can be
frustrating just because there are the
accuracy issues he is a little bit
unpredictable he tends to play outside
the offense a little bit so I do know
the receivers have been through there in
the past because cam isn't the most
conventional quarterback that have been
frustrated and it felt like their
productions been affected by playing
with them and you know I it's not hard
to see where Kelvin Benjamin now a
former first-round pick would be going
you know into the end of his rookie
contract and looking back at it and
saying this guy might have cost me some
money and so I you know I think that
that absolutely exists and I think
that's something that North Turner's got
turned the new offensive coach Darren
Carolina are trying to work on now where
they're trying to get him to play within
the office not taking away what he does
well but make him a little bit more
efficient again they could use the
office
advantage a little bit more and you know
part of it was you know Dave gentleman's
decision before he was fired 2017 to
draft Christian Christian McCaffrey and
Curtis Samuel to try to create more easy
completions for them and so they've
tried to make him more efficient as a
passer I think you can also argue that
his best Cam Newton is any
unconventional player and a lot of times
for receivers it could be frustrated to
play with a quarterback like that first
rookie quarterback to start will be Sam
Donald I think Sam job has the best shot
right now I say he has a better than
50/50 shot to start against Detroit and
week one and I think it's really about
how he handled last year at SC number
one took a lot of hits and was able to
compartmentalize mistakes which are two
things you're going to need to be able
to do as a rookie and so that's number
one and then number two he's made great
progress in his three months since he's
doing the building
and he's a quick study the one thing
that's interesting about him Dan is he
actually hasn't played quarterback for
that long he was a linebacker a
sophomore in high school he's not one of
these classically trained guys who had a
you know a personal coach when he was
eight or nine years old he's still
learning the position so there's a lot
of growth potential there and he's sort
of figured it out athletically and the
time since he's become a quarterback and
so I think that they believe that he
does everything right over the next
three or four weeks it's gonna be hard
to keep him on the best show I think
Darnell's got the best chance could be
starting week one of all the worthy
quarterbacks I would click Josh Rosen
second good stuff Albert thank you we
appreciate your time safe travels
I think that's Albert Breer mmq b NBC
Sports Boston for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]